[Musique]
qui a tué des mémos
irresponsable et pourquoi
[Musique]
tout le monde est étonné d alcool parce
que on en vit dans un milieu d'enfants
très dur très difficile avec beaucoup
d'agressivité
et j'ai noté chez stéphane calme
différent de gitans que j'ai connus qui
était justement très agressif
gentil garçon en plus des cinq classes
essayant de faire son possible
mais on ne pensait pas du tout qu'il
faisait de la boxe et c'était un futur
bon boxeur
pour lui je suppose que c'est la bonne
solution ça lui amènera peut-être
quelque chose d'autre que ce qu'il
attend plus tard parce que je ne sais
pas si cet enfant pourra faire un métier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il boxe rapidement mais sans chercher à
assouan cette façon il a du tempérament
[Musique]
il a l'air d'aimer ça ça lui donne
confiance à lui permet de s'exprimer on
a droit à
l'enfant qui est timide fait de la boxe
pour se défendre plus tard pour pouvoir
respecter
c'est une école de maîtrise et une école
de pour devenir un pour devenir un homme
s'est fait la selaçao certainement à
tout athlète qui
sera pas voilà c'est déjà
bien développé pour son âge il sera peut
être choquant paru être champion de
france
ça de la multiplication sur l'addition
c'est à dire qu'on va d'abord
toute façon faut qu'ils soient au moins
stables pour être professionnel et puis
alors à 24 ans bombe à 24 ans c'est la
boisson nationale c'est autre chose
c'est déjà plus dur
irresponsable et pourquoi les hommes
[Musique]
colère nous avons est assez cher c'est
bien dommage mais entre nous
c'est la photo de what the way il
s'entraîne à la même strate côtoient
qu'il a déjà vu à l'entraînement
qu'est ce qu'on pense
mon modèle
[Musique]
c'est un peu ton père qui t'a amené à
faire là bas
comment ça s'est passé
ils sont là ça m'a pas plu dès le début
ça me
on n'a pas plu du tout
et a pas eu peur
non parce que je regardais dans ton
cahier de thaler tu as la photo d'un
boxeur
qui est mort sur le ring
[Musique]
sur lequel on a fait une chanson
d'avis baulois
c'est quand même un peu impressionnant
une autre fois je voulais le faire
arrêter je vais devoir une fois ça
n'avait pas bien plus je voulais qu'ils
arrêtent et puis après j'ai dit non non
je continue la gelée laisser conter n'ai
jamais pensé
l'accident qui vous est arrivé c'était
un sport dangereux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non pas qu'il soit défiguré comme
commandant rouge
quand tu seras tu continueras 5 17 ans
tu feras encore là bas
[Applaudissements]
et tu vas en serre
que je mettrais après
on rêve de boxeur
de montner champions champions cette
fois le champion du monde
s'il veut en faire un métier à ce moment
là je pense d'ailleurs pechiney enfin
on verra bien d'ici là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un métier
il n'en sera peut-être pas son métier
mais
donc ça ira mieux je le serai vivant que
ça se passe mal pour lui je faire voter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les yeux la bouche fort dans la
d'accord les mains
très bien ok at il est ou sur
l'adversaire qu'on le voit en même temps
comme ça c
est bien
le tass
ça se passe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tombé
sur ces séries à fort
c'est moi
de serrer la main mais
janot certaines intrigues les chasser
l'eau spge annoncé aimait bien que mal
les mots reviennent
toujours légaux gens
on a droit triste que tu coules
diego s'en
vient dans l'île
[Applaudissements]
droite
jean
dutourd est la part de sa
maladie
le manager h f
oui c'est ça oui
je respire bien
fatigués
arrêter certaines précisions
convaincu aspirent
tu aspires diverses père très forts stop
tu souffrais pas par les miens
[Applaudissements]
gauche gauche
est un droit et oui jean
tu touches et upa
torben ludovic
resté serré la main ils sont assez
grands tous saluent qui salue c'est ok
c'est pas grave c'est moi du coup
c'est pas grave ça c'est la boxe
c'est bien
un mot sur la patate
[Musique]
pas mal non
c'est ma boîte à la mode normal partout
notre océan
oui on arrive
ça va c'est pas
la fin
et mon fils
par ailleurs or à bien parce qu'un
accord qui volent sur la la c'est
exactement la main exactement la même
façon
ok
et elle
bien cher est debout en face à cela vaut
une bonne la timbale se révéler
[ __ ] ça
ce sont des gars respire bien
mais bien les morts
[Musique]
tu respires très très fort et puis
chasse bien ok c'est ça c'est bien te
dirais qui tu reviens tu à droite
derrière
calme
[Applaudissements]
une fois ce pas
bientôt
sur la droite c'est pas un peu frais
oui
yade en ligne puteaux nanterre
[Musique]
on se dégage
oui
beaucoup à droite
déplacé à droite
un peu plus près
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu respires viard
j'étais groupe touche adverse et les
chasser
pas paniquer
un livre appuyé sur l'eczéma
il est vrai
j'avance un petit peu c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
whittall a surpassé
tu tournes adroit de ses fans
[Applaudissements]
c'est trop loin à 6
le cuir revient voilà
gauche gauche et droite
je qui
venir
je n'aurais pas dû le faire y fait très
bien
[Musique]
ouais il allait mieux basa
ses fans
les voix sont pas connues
m
cuba il a pris la fuite ou la boxe est
maintenant interdite je les frappe et
bien sûr ça c'est vrai et pour ce boulot
en me paye ne dis pas qu'il ait tué
après tout c'est le destin
[Musique]